welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul aka the spoiler man
and with season two of the boys ending
on a big cliffhanger i thought we'd take
some time out to properly discuss our
theories on the upcoming season
obviously there will be heavy spoilers
here in regards to elements of the show
and comic so if you don't want anything
ruined then i recommend that you turn
off now
please drop a thumbs up if you enjoy the
video and don't forget to subscribe to
the channel for boys content over the
next coming weeks
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into our theories
okay so the first thing we have to talk
about is victoria newman
the explosive finale revealed that she
was actually the person behind the head
popping the entire time
and after re-watching the series i think
it becomes more and more obvious
that she's actually working for vort and
is simply helping them to play the
political landscape
so that they can win no matter what i
did kind of go back and forth on this
for some time
as there were two ways of thinking with
her with some saying that she was a
rogue soup
whereas the other theory is that she was
a vote puppet all along
however i have settled on the latter way
of thinking
and due to several clues in the series
it seems like she's
bought and paid for eh having that now
this is mainly because edgar is always
watching her
rather than the news whenever we cut to
his office reiner states it's a coup
from the inside before she gets taken
out
and vic only tends to act when vo are in
danger of being exposed
it also explains how she got her powers
as we learned from the sage grove center
that they were indeed experimenting on
people with compound b
the comics as well give us a big clue
and vic the veep who her character is
based on
is actually the former ceo of vort who
infiltrates the white house through the
position of vice president
before he kills the main man and takes
over his job
i can see this being the case in the
show too and we end with her seat in
congress being secured whilst she
continues her political campaign
actually think that for the third season
we will get somewhat of a time
jump and may even pick up after a
year-long hiatus
and see her heading to the vice
presidency the second season
ended by feeling like it was somewhat of
a conclusion to the main arc of the boys
and though there were still a lot of
open-ended elements
i think that the characters do deserve a
bit of a break
this will give the characters time to
reflect on what's going on
and it also gives fort a chance to
rebuild and move victoria up the
political ladder
here she will be able to push compound v
to the public which will then drive up
the stock prices of vought in the long
run
due to her powers when she's in the
position of vice president
she can also take out the president
himself and make it look like another
attack
that's where i think cindy will come
into play and if you watched our episode
7 breakdown of season 2
then you'll know that we mistakenly
believed that it would be cindy who was
revealed behind the attack on the
hearing
i think she's still out in the wild for
a reason and this will further hammer
home the super terrorist threat
which will enable vic to push v even
more and raise the stock prices
it seems like it's a great time to
invest in vote now the boys will
obviously figure out that
throughout the majority of season 2 they
were helping vote the entire time
and this will come as a massive shock to
them i think
they are basically the bad guys and i
believe that huey will discover vick's
true motives
before he gets the group back together
to take her and vote down
now with invart there are also several
things that could happen
firstly from the finale it does look
like stormfront is still alive
i think that she will return for the
third season though
not be as much of a focus as she was
here we know from when she had her tats
lasered
that she can heal from burns quite
quickly so i do think that she will
recover from ryan's laser blasts
i'm not sure if she can regrow limbs
though so
if she does return she may be confined
to a hospital bed
i think iacash did a fantastic job in
this season though so if we can't get
her back in any form
i'll be happy now because of her
political leanings
bought are gonna have to do a lot of
positive pr in order to get the country
back on their side
i think they're going to go a little
old-fashioned with it and bring out
someone who represents truth
justice and the american way and being
an
absolute psychopath that is soldier boy
soldier boy was actually the first
character that i saw confirmed for
season 3
and he's going to be played by jensen
ackles eric kripke the boys showrunner
discussed his appearance and actually
gave us some hints of how he was going
to be portrayed
in an interview with variety the creator
stated the following
i think anyone expecting jensen to show
up and be a good guy
they will be disappointed i'll say that
in the comics he's mostly just kind of
bumbling and subservient to homelander
and as we're writing him in this
we're getting to really talk about the
history of vort because he's like john
wayne
he's one of those guys that's been
around for decades of vote history
and he was homelander before homelander
so he's from a different era
but he's got the ego and the ambition it
just comes across
in a different way because he's from a
different time
now we do have it confirmed that the
character will actually be the original
soulja boy i think that vo may have
frozen him in order to bring him out for
such an event
they will have done this on purpose a la
austin powers
but will likely come up with some
marvel-esque story about how he was
found frozen on ice
or something along those lines in case
you don't know would pretty much
manufacture all the origin stories for
the seven
and at one point they even convinced the
public that homelander was actually an
alien from a dying planet
though v is well known at this point i
think they will brush it to the side and
go back to trying to peddle these comic
book origin stories
and as soulja boy is seen as the first
superhero
this will be easier to achieve now we do
know that the gay scene that homelander
and soulja boy share
will not be in the series however kripke
did say that it would be replaced by
something else
that fans will appreciate and that is
herogasm
as for homelander we know that he's
gonna go fully off the deep end
and i can't wait to see what happens
with him ign
recently posted an article that stated
homelander was going to be let off the
leash in season 3
and that he would fully embrace his more
murderous mind state
the article has had a lot of backlash
with people saying that he was already
like that
and though i hate ign as much as the
next person
i have to say that he still has kind of
been toned down
as demonstrated by the crowd scene in
which he just imagined
massacring tons of people instead of
actually doing it
season 3 it seems will be him just going
all out
and the second season ended with us
really starting to understand why
if you look at things from his point of
view he was betrayed by his own son who
decided to side with billy instead of
him
his teammates namely maven starlight
sold him out
and bought tried to take back ryan so
that they had something to hold over his
head
all homelander wants to do is to be
loved and thus
him getting double crossed by everyone
in his life will make him realize that
he should just do whatever he wants now
shout out to the weekly planet podcast
for discussing this in full detail
and definitely check that out after this
as they go into a lot more the thinking
behind homelanders position at the end
the bloody great blokes as well so so
give them a listen
now with homelander turning on his own
it's only really gonna lead one way
and that is the death of maeve in the
comics the character actually kills her
and i can't see that being carried
across here before he returns to his son
to try and either repair their
relationship or end it completely on his
terms
speaking of ryan it's also possible that
the cia
may set him up as their own superhero
who could fill the shoes of soldier boy
further down the line superhero nexus
recently pointed out that
just like how ryan can easily name the
us states soulja boy does this in the
comics too
in the upcoming show falcon in the
winter soldier marvel are going to be
introducing a government appointed
captain america
known as u.s agent and i think that the
cia may do the same thing with ryan
in the comics we learn that the soulja
boy we see is actually the third
incarnation of the character
so it does leave the door open for
others to take up the mantle
the fate of black noir is currently
unknown too
and though he is hospitalized we're
still unsure
whether he's going to be back personally
i think he's too good to pass up
as the character is unintentionally
hilarious
but also as intimidating as hell when he
wants to be
and there's a lot that you can do with
him it does seem like they're straying
from his arc in the comic books
but i think they will actually do
something with him that was in the
source material
that is that he will become an even more
zombie-like character
who is completely unfeeling in the
source material we learn that compound v
can actually be used to bring the dead
back to life
another person who's resurrected isn't
in the best condition mentally
they are still able to be an asset to
vote i think that noir will fill this
role
and he will become even more of an
unkillable monster
that's completely unstable i know fans
of the comics might be disappointed that
they don't stick to the twist in that
but it's so well known in the community
at this point that it's not really going
to surprise anyone if it comes true
as for the deep well the leader of the
church is now being taken out
and i can't really see us touching base
with the collective as the deep has now
left them
i'm praying we get another season of
healing and reflection for him
as i love to get deep when it comes to
the deep and you know what
he's probably in my top three characters
right now
and finally there's huey's mother who
had some lip
service paid to her in the show but
nothing that substantial beyond the fact
that she walked out on him and his
father when he was six years old
in the comic books huey was actually
adopted and didn't know either of his
parents
so the fact we learn about his real
mother i think has been done for a
reason
i do think that she will be connected to
vote in some way and that she may have
had to go on the run from the
corporation
which is why she headed out without
really saying goodbye
as we know from how the corporation were
with annie they won't let anyone get
away from them
if they can control it and i think that
we may discover that they were behind
her disappearance in some way
maybe noir killed her i don't know but
that's our theories and predictions
and obviously i'd love to hear yours
there's no doubt going to be a ton of
things to talk about
so make sure you leave your thoughts in
the comments section below if you
enjoyed this video and want something
else to watch then definitely check out
our full breakdown of victoria newman
which is going to be linked at the end
we go over her comic book origins and
role in the show
so it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more don't forget we're
also giving away three copies of the
marvel phase one box set
and all you have to do to be with the
chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below
the winner is going to be chosen at
random on the 30th of october and the
set will be shipped out from then to
ever gets the prize
so best of luck to everyone who takes
part if you want to support the channel
and get to see content early
then please consider clicking the john
button below you can also come chatters
on the discord server linked in the
description
or heavy spoilers on twitter thanks for
making it until the end of the video
you've been the best i've been paul and
i'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
you